i'm joined now from westminster by
labour's shadow cultural secretary lucy
powell thank you very much for being
with us if i may just a quick word on
broader issues how do you think
the west and the uk should react to
president putin putting his forces or
nuclear forces on alert
well it's good to see such a united
response i think from the eu from nato
allies and others and yeah we all we ask
for is that we want that to go further
and be tougher
the main way we can support the
ukrainian people who are fleeing their
homes at the moment they don't want to
be doing that the main way we can
support them is by giving them further
military aid and by inflicting the
toughest possible economic cultural and
sporting sanctions
on russia to try and bring this evasion
invasion to
a
a abrupt end or to at least minimize its
its impact and uh you know reports that
you're you're making this morning from
ukraine would suggest that you know some
of that is is stalled uh from the russia
side but yeah we want to see united
front and the toughest possible actions
that we can bring
yeah i mean i was just thinking more
broadly we're entering quite possibly an
era of confrontation uh with russia
would labor support
an increase now in uk defense spending
an increase
not that's not a decision for for me to
make uh on this program but we fully
support you know having uh
adequate uh and and enough uh defense uh
capability and spending you know our
spending's not always been that much
effective
over recent years we've had some of the
spending there but it's been in the in
the wrong places with the with the wrong
capabilities being invested in
but of course you know we are now
entering a new era and that means we
have to reflect that in our priorities
as a country and being able to to
withstand
a despot deranged leader like putin
means that we we do have to reflect and
look at what our
capabilities are but we stand firmly
behind our military we found stand
firmly uh with our nato allies and our
support of nato and the the wider
defense agenda you know it is unwavering
as the labour party
yeah i'm not asking you to make any
decisions obviously that's not for you
but would you support do you think we're
entering a dangerous period in
you know western russian relations where
we should all be thinking about
increasing defense spending now well
absolutely i mean this is one of the
most
i think terrifying eras uh of of my
lifetime you know i never
we didn't ever think did we as a
generation that we would see such a
blatant um breach of of those
international norms that we've we've
been living with for decades now with a
an illegal invasion on a european uh
country on our doorstep by russia and
that requires
that is going to require a radical
rethink in in terms of our
public policy our foreign policy our
defense policy and so on and you know i
think
uk
nato the west we are
really waking up to to that that new
threat and um you know we have
a united
agenda here now i think we have seen
tough action but it could be tougher
still and and we want we want the uk
government we want other governments to
go further when it comes to those
economic sanctions tackling the
oligarchs that take safe haven in our
country and when it comes to things like
sporting and cultural
sanctions and also
increasing that that military aid
directly into ukraine so that the
ukrainian people can defend
a themselves word on sport i mean sport
does appear as if it's
um stepping up to the plate on this what
more would you want um sporting bodies
and cultural organizations to do
well we are seeing some moves in the
right direction with uefa
and to some degree with with fifa
football and others but i think we need
to send a clear and categoric message
that russia from now on will be fully
excluded uh fully uh boycotted from all
international sporting and cultural
events so things like the upcoming world
cup uh it shouldn't be a case that
russia can still take part be it with
without
displaying its country's name they
should be excluded from that event
without delay uh we've got the the
women's euro finals taking place here in
the uk in the summer the same two world
chess championships
they're still hosting international
volleyball and swimming competitions
later this year i think we now need to
see a full and clear categoric signal
so that putin who takes these occasions
very seriously when he's hosting or when
he's participating uh in these events he
needs to feel the full force of that
where it hurts and it will send a strong
signal to the russian people as well
that they need to stand up to to putin
because they'll no longer be able to
take pride in in their country taking
part in such events
okay lucy powell thanks very much